we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
here is an interesting take about donald
trump's distraction
of joe biden via interruption during the
tuesday night debate take a listen hi
david
i listen to you every day i really enjoy
your show i just have one comment about
the debate
as if trump had been yammering and
screaming and yelling so much at joe
biden
i think joe would have done a lot better
it was hard to concentrate i'm surprised
he didn't lose his focus more often i
mean it was hard just
sitting here listening to it and trying
to keep track of what was going on
so that that's my only remark i just
wondered what you thought about that
i think it's completely plausible that
donald trump with his preconceived
notion
that biden will lose his train of
thought that bidens uh
trump's strategy trump's interruptions
were not just trump being an unhinged
petulant child but it was the idea that
trump thought if i keep interrupting
it's going to throw joe off his game
and he's going to fall apart now i think
it definitely rattled biden early
but once it became clear that chris
wallace was not going to be able to take
control of it
joe biden figured out what to do and it
included at some point
saying you know will you shut up man
you're a clown and that type of thing
at other points just kind of powering
through trump's interruptions so
i i i do anybody would be distracted by
that if you're trying to speak
coherently about policy as joe biden was
trying to do
and someone's just yammering yammering
and they won't shut up
anybody would get distracted by it i do
think it was a trump strategy
and i think by the second half of the
bait of the debate joe biden
better handled it the commission now
says they're going to change some of the
rules
because of trump's interruptions during
the upcoming debates
we will see what those rule changes are
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we have a counter offer
coveted relief bill presented to nancy
pelosi by steven mnuchin we will discuss
it we will talk about the latest bizarre
legal argument being made by tucker
carlson's
lawyers and much more get instant access
to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com